et on démarre cette matinale avec le
dossier ukrainien et washington qui
maintient la pression malgré le retrait
d'une partie des troupes russes à la
frontière ukrainienne joe biden qui
s'est exprimé hier soir quelques heures
après un entretien téléphonique entre
les chefs de la diplomatie russe et
américain les précisions à washington de
notre reporter thomas bouteille
joe biden a délivré ce mardi à un
discours d'une dizaine de minutes au
cours duquel il n'a répondu à aucune
question il s'agissait en réalité d'une
allocution comme un point d'étape sur la
situation en ukraine selon le président
américain il ya toujours deux options
sur la table et les etats-unis dit-il se
tiennent prêts pour ces deux
possibilités la première option c'est
celle de la voie diplomatique pour
résoudre cette crise en ukraine les
etats unis qui seront également prêts à
répondre en cas d'attaqué de la russie
contre l'ukraine voilà ce que déclare
joe biden qui est également revenu sur
son entretien du week-end avec vladimir
poutine le président russe et moi sommes
d'accord pour poursuivre les discussions
déclare joe biden écoutez le hier le
gouvernement russe a publiquement
proposé de continuer vers la voie
diplomatique
et je suis d'accord nous devons donner
toutes ses chances de succès à la
diplomatie je pense qu'il existe une
véritable possibilité de respecter la
sécurité de chacun le président
américain qui affirme que les nations
ont le droit de choisir leur alliance et
avec qui elle s'associe il est également
revenu sur la situation le long de la
frontière entre la russie et l'ukraine
les services de renseignement américains
dit il ne sont pas en mesure de vérifier
les informations selon lesquelles des
troupes militaires russes sont en train
de quitter la région écoutez les détails
donnés par joe biden le ministère russe
de la défense a annoncé aujourd'hui que
certains militaires russes doivent
quitter leur position aux abords de
l'ukraine
ce serait une bonne chose mais nous
n'avons pas encore vérifié cette
information
nous n'avons pas encore pu vérifier si
les militaires russes ont bien regagné
leurs bases joe biden qui est également
revenu sur la décision de déplacer
l'ambassade américaine de kiev vers
l'ouest de crenn washington qui exhorte
toujours les ressortissants américains à
quitter le pays au plus vite et puis joe
biden s'est adressé directement aux
citoyens russes il leur dit vous n'êtes
pas nos ennemis on ne veut pas
déstabiliser la russie voilà pour les
déclarations de joe biden qui a une
nouvelle fois agité la menace de
sanctions puissante et qui sont prêtes
selon le locataire de la maison blanche
on comprend qu elles viseront notamment
le gazoduc north stream 2 qui selon joe
biden n'entrera pas en activité en cas
d' attaques de la russie contre
l'ukraine ce discours prononcé par le
président américain ce mardi est
intervenue quelques heures après un
entretien téléphonique qui s'est déroulé
la même journée entre sergueï lavrov et
son homologue américain anthony blinken